out here
[Music]
oh
ain't nothing wrong with that
he got shot
and that's bad even in the western bank
is
one
right
wow
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well
uh
[Music]
yes
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
i believe
okay
um
thank you
thank you
okay
yes
oh
okay
i love your socks
[Music]
are they great
please
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
up
um
thank you
uh
let's look
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
yes
oh
[Music]
okay
okay
uh
here
laughs
bye
[Applause]
oh
the numbers
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
yes
me
oh
okay
thank you
i need everybody to back up and i just
need i
just need the family an immediate family
as we we had had conversation this
morning if i need hunts
i need arthur i need my husband
everybody
and the rest of the immediate family can
everybody respect that and back off
for these families and get answers
because y'all please just back up
all people in the heart and the
immediate family so can all the hot
and immediate families come to the door
hello
oh
[Music]
that's right
yes
oh
okay
hey
um
um
oh
just like this
everybody can get back
all right
thank you for your patience
again i'm attorney ben crump along with
attorney picard sellers attorney harry
daniels
attorney wayne kendall and attorney
shante
lasseter we have the honor of fighting
for the family of andrew brown
jr for transparency
accountability and truth
what we witnessed here our legal team
and you're going to hear from
our legal team who got to witness the
video and then you're going to hear from
the family members and then we'll take
your questions
we want to say on the record from the
onset
we do not feel that we got transparency
we only saw a snippet
of the video when we know
that the video started before
and after where they showed the family
and they determined what was pertinent
why couldn't the family see all the
video
they only showed one body cam video
even though we know there were several
body cam videos
if they were following the law and the
policy
in this county that everybody has video
cameras on
their uniforms
furthermore
and you're going to hear from attorney
sellers and attorney daniels on
this matter to add insult to injury
they wanted to have just the
two family members see the video with no
legal counsel
as if they did not have a right to have
their legal counsel
present when they watch this execution
of their loved one
and we have to keep demanding
transparency
because we do not feel what the county
attorney
offered was transparency
at all and so it's very emotional
not only the video but how this family
was disrespected
even in the aftermath you talk about
insult
on top of injury but be not dismayed
the truth will come out the video will
be
seen by the public and we will get
justice
for andrew brown jr these police
officers will be held accountable
at this time uh a great i know
you all know him uh from his political
commentary
on cnn but he is a great
civil rights attorney as well he's going
to
speak to you and then he's going to be
followed by attorney daniels
and then we're going to have attorney
lassiter
who is going to tell you blow by blow
what was seen in just that snippet that
22nd video that we know is much fun
attorney for carson so we want to
we want to highlight i want to highlight
the the disrespect
to this family i want to highlight
the broken system of justice we have in
this country
as we're going through this process we
told the family that they would have
their attorneys in there at some comfort
we went back and forth and i just want
you to say i've never been talked to
like i was talked to in there
i don't know his name but uh i went mike
thompson listen i
i went to the back and i know that we're
live
on the news around the world so i will
say that
mr cox told me a grown black man that he
was not
[ __ ] going to be bullied
so i i walked out and i want you to know
that
the sheriff was very very
apologetic and diplomatic the sheriff
wanted to make sure that the family saw
the video but it was the county attorney
that gave us this back and forth but
let's not focus just on the disrespect
shown to me let's focus on the
disrespect shown to this family
one body cam
20 seconds
one body cam 20 seconds
welcome to north carolina and execution
and so with all due respect i know there
were a lot of people who thought last
week's verdict was justice and i told
you then it wasn't justice
because we still can't get justice and
accountability today i'm only going to
be brief because
i'm hot right now
[Music]
but i do want to say a special a special
prayer goes out to this family
because khalil saw his father executed
wow but he's been the strongest one of
us all come on
yeah so let them up in your prayers
amen and then as we say in south
carolina i know we in north carolina to
the county attorney and everybody else
bless his heart right thank you burkari
uh and now you're gonna hear from
another great
civil rights lawyer who hails out of
atlanta georgia who
has actually been in communications
with the county attorney for
uh days trying to get this process set
and he's litigated matters all over the
country
and never had he's been disrespected
like he was today he's going to tell you
his perspective before i bring on
attorney lazar
uh attorney harry daniels who's been
diagnosed and crossing tees
for the family thank you ben
1965 salmon alabama it was bloody sunday
a resistance for fundamental rights to
vote
rights to vote this family
had a fundamental right for transparency
that was denied denied by the county
officials
of pasco tank county specifically the
county attorney
because he does not interpret the laws
of north carolina
his position that you had to be an
authorized a licensed attorney
in the state of north carolina to
represent vote
i offered him the ability to to read the
state bar
rules the rules of the bar he didn't
want to read it we offered attorney
general to it
he didn't want to talk to him we offered
a governor he told the car he's not
going to be bullied
20 seconds 20 seconds
is not transparency when you got
multiple officers
gunning down a man with his hands on the
steering wheel and trying to get away
we will have justice we will have
justice amen i've been have you ever
never have you ever in all your time
you've been doing this have you ever
seen this before
never i mean
[Music]
attorney daniels and attorney sellers
they were trying to reason with him
and say that we are lawyers retained by
the family
we the american constitution gives
citizens
the right to have the lawyer of their
own choosing
and he tried to tell us no if you're not
born in north carolina
this family does not have the right
to say my lawyer can watch the video
with me
and harry quoted the statue of verbatim
and it never once said narcotics
from the statute there's nothing to say
north carolina whatsoever you can
associate with attorney in north
carolina
pro vta is not does not mean
that you cannot associate and hire any
attorney you want in the united states
well that's right
in the united states ben can hire me i
can hire business my counselor yeah
that's right
all right thank you so much attorney
daniels for
covering that and it got real emotional
because attorney daniels had been
working with them we wanted this process
to be seamless
i mean we have verbal conversation
confirmation we had
written confirmation only to be told
at the 11th hour that no only the family
is going to come in
that be as it may we have
a great member of our legal team
who hails here in the state of north
carolina
in fact she's right here from elizabeth
city north carolina
and not only is she a great lawyer
she is the attorney who had been
representing andrew brown
jr and his family even before this
tragedy happened
and she knew them so this is very
personal and this is very painful
but she was tasked with the
responsibility
to watch whatever video they were going
to allow to sea
even though harry potter we didn't know
it was going to be a 20-second snippet
she watched it and she documented it
over and over again to make sure
she could relate to you all what
happened
so when you heard from the family you
didn't have to rely
solely on them because their heart was
breaking
as they watched the video in fact
patrice had to run out the room she
couldn't take it uh
and thank god as picard said khalil
he stood there and represented his
family
as they watched that video probably 10
to 20 times
knowing every time it ended with them
executing his father
20 seconds so attorney
katrice lasseter will now tell you
i'm sorry attorney chantel lasseter will
now tell you
what this video
demonstrated yeah and she may refer to
her notes but it's
it's pretty clear what they did we know
why they want to keep it from
attorney lasseter and khalil
take it down as loud as you can
y'all please be quiet so because trees
won't have to scream
let's be clear this was the execution
andrew brown was in his driveway
the sheriff chuck locked him in his
driveway so he could not exit his
driveway
andrew had his hands on his steering
wheel he was not reaching for anything
he wasn't touching anything he wasn't
throwing anything around he had his
hands
firmly on the steering wheel they run up
to his vehicle
shooting
he in stood there sat there in his
vehicle with his hands on the steering
wheel while being shot at
now keep in mind this is 20 seconds i
have three pages of notes
for 20 seconds we watched this over and
over and over
to make sure we were clear at what was
being
going on and what was transparent
he finally decides to try to get away
and he backs
out not going towards officers at all
there was
at no time in the 20 seconds that we saw
where he was
threatening the officers in any kind of
way that's right
he was trying to evade being shot yes
so he backs out not forward the backs
out away from the officers
who still shooting at him yelling stop
it [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] constant obsessed
he's being yelled at him while he's been
shot at
in the driveway of his home in pascotte
county north carolina
i'm taking my time y'all but it was 20
seconds
he finally backs out and then he goes
around to get out
of danger he goes around still avoiding
any interaction with officers still
trying to make sure he did not
threaten them in any way that they were
not in danger in any way
he backs out goes around them and
they're still shooting at him
while he's driving off he drives off the
car
runs into a tree and they are still
running behind him
let me make sure i get this right with
these guns that were there wow
17 handguns it was numerous so those
were salt
a numerous assault rifles were at the
theme yes
we saw one vehicle one one video 20
seconds from one body cam
it was at least eight officers there we
only saw one one body cam
it was a chef's truck there we didn't
see any dash cam video we just saw that
one
body cam who we
yeah he was still i just want to make it
clear that he was he had that was just
shooting at him after the car had
already crashed into a tree
they were still still in the stance of
shooting towards him
his part riddled with bullets from them
shooting at him he was not in any
threatening them in any kind of any kind
of formal passion and even before
it started they had share occasions
before and thankfully khalil noticed and
we
we kept rewinding the tape there were
shell casings before he even backed out
yeah
so they were shooting at him and he was
sitting there with his right with his
hands on the steering wheel
in the driveway and before the video
started and
so also we only saw again i want to i
want y'all know about his 20 seconds
there was things that transpired before
those 20 seconds that we did we did not
see so i don't know how many shots was
fired
before the little 20 seconds they
allowed us to see i know it shots in
that windshield before he was even able
to back out of his driveway
and i want to open up did you watch him
yeah just step right here in the center
i want your mom which
it's like we against all odds in this
world
my dad got executed just by trying to
save his own life
you know he was not in no the office was
not in no harm of him
at all it's just messed up how this
happened man
he got executed it ain't right
it ain't right at all
at this time the attorneys will try to
answer some of your questions
let me also just uh tell my friends in
the media
i think we learned this from the case of
george floyd
that after the night of the incident
where george floyd was murdered
the police department put out a press
release that said
man dies from medical incident
and i want you to keep that fresh in
your mind because i want all of you all
to help us
i want every single camera out here to
help us
because do not let them pass off 20
seconds from
eight different cameras right
not giving us the dash cam video and the
fact we know there were cameras
on the house and on other polls
that they they they have possessions i
want my friends in the media
to go out and demand justice for the
country to see
right yeah this is a this is bigger than
this is bigger than andrew that's right
you know god uses that god uses us in
mysterious ways
and i looked at khalil before we went in
and i said khalil you about to see
something you ain't never seen before
i can't imagine what it would be like to
see my dad executed on camera
but khalil stayed strong he stood strong
but he
is now a victim of a broken system
from the way they interacted to the way
they're covering it up
yeah so with that i guess you take some
questions harry and ben
i took the bar exam a few times they
smarter than i am
i will say this roland martin and all
the media
why is it that they get to choose what's
the pertinent parts
of the video to show the family i mean
wasn't the law critically they they were
going to show the video
to the family and then at the last
minute harry they decided that
oh we gonna redact it and all this stuff
where is that written in the statue that
the
family doesn't have the right to see the
entire video
are they going to only try to show the
public
the pertinent parts so say them
come on now are we going to get to see
the whole video
all nine body cameras that were
available
all the dash cam from the police car
that was available
and then attorney uh kendall
you said there was a camera on the light
pole we want
all of it because that's what
transparency is
let us see with our own eyes we don't
need you to interpret it for us
do we know how many different officers
were firing at this point
if you want to have someone thank you
and you can answer yeah
how many shots did you hear in that 20
seconds and could you tell
how many officers were firing it was at
least seven or eight officers there
and the number they were real enough you
know um
we lost count it's 20 seconds or we lost
count in 20 seconds how many shots
um the video you saw
was the police vehicle mark or unmarked
smart
was marked yes were they in uniform or
were they not some of them was in swat
some of them had on uh jeans
and khakis with the upper part in
uniform in the audio portion did you
hear them
identify themselves do you hear them say
to him
who they were and you need to stop they
had cut that part out we didn't
20 seconds didn't get a lot all we all
they said was um
look at my note make sure i get it
correct
second one gunstrong pointing at him
while his hands are on the steering
wheel
let me see your hands his hands on the
steering wheel
it was at least five on the driver's
side pointing the guns at him
let me see your hands that's what
started at the one second mark so
you did not see the beginning them
driving up you don't see that
no the beginning of this video was them
standing shooting guns
not before but what you saw soon the
video starts you already hear shots
yes and to my understanding the body cam
that was shown was an officer
furthest away not the officers who's
right in front of him right but that's
the body cam they showed so
there were five cops standing on the
driver's side
you did not see the body cam from those
five cops that one
oh no we didn't see that so what was the
vantage point behind the car side of the
car on the side of the car running
across the street
so he was running the officer that we
saw from the other side of the truck
right so it wasn't the ones who was
shooting he was shooting through at some
point but he's further away
yes in the video the video started with
the shots coming
it was an execution in elizabeth city
from second one
yeah what what struck you
one they're moment
and saying let me see your hands at the
same time and he's complaining
why you and make sure and he's complying
his hand is on the steering wheels even
though he's compliant they still
shooting at it
so at what point did the car be moving
did it ever go in reverse or was it
always forward in the clip that you saw
it was always deciding reverse he didn't
he was intentionally trying not to hit
officers he backed up instead of going
forward towards
them he backed up and then went all the
way around trying to intentionally not
hit the officers
watching the video today no no i presume
the video after you all first thought
that you were a little surprised that
you only thought 20 seconds
did you ask why you only saw that about
and what was your first thought when you
realized really let me i said when we
first went in
they asked we had any questions i said i
said yes how long is the video
he said and i say he the county attorney
so i'm only going to show you
the pertinent part so the pertinent
parts was 20 seconds of them
not the part that they would shoot
before the video came on
so that the pertinent part is declined i
mean i'm sorry mr brown gets
shot at before
the video starts but they didn't want to
show that to us no
that wasn't pertinent to them yeah what
led up to the shooting was not perfect
as to why he said 20 seconds only the
amount of times you need to see
for this video you gotta let me let me
just help you all answer the questions
about the discernment
between what was shown and what was not
shown you gotta ask them
yeah they they gonna come out of one of
these doors
and y'all you know not y'all but they
have done a good enough job
of putting out the warrants they're
going to talk about his record we know
we know
they're going to say everything bad
they're going to call him everything but
a child of god
right so we don't
we don't know the answer to that they
give you an indication they'll show you
more video later
they said on wednesday they going to
court how many officers are we looking
for charging
they should be arrested right now right
answer that question because obviously
we in black america don't understand
why when a black person is going away
from you
you think it's allowable to shoot them
in the back
and kill them so i believe
if the law says carry that you're not
posing a threat or fear and you still
kill somebody
that's murder all right that was an
assassination
lack of explanation when everyone in the
family and the attorneys have been
seeking some of the answers well i got
cussed out today so i don't feel good
about it
can y'all can y'all walk us through who
was controlling this whole process
county attorney michael cox the county
attorney you should direct your
questions
towards him the share and i'm gonna be i
want to be completely honest with
everybody
the sheriff's perspective was he wanted
the family to be able to see the video
today
that's what he stated he said the family
came he wanted him to see the video
he said he was and i don't have any
reason not to say he said i don't know
who i don't know we're not going to
dictate what's on it what's not
we're not going to dictate who's in the
room who's not all these decisions were
made by the county
and i can't tell you why they made those
decisions but i know he's still here
when you say the county council
was the district attorney or anyone from
their office no no no that's one of the
best questions we can ask
today as as journalists one of the
questions that i want you all to ask and
i will come next one of the questions i
want you to ask is how do you redact
how do you redact body cam video
without the prosecuting agents right
okay right so if i'm outside and i
commit a crime
you can't have somebody that works with
you every single day redact the video
right and decide what's pertinent
um no idea
we don't know whether it's unknown we
don't know
it's more given your interaction with
this attorney today
what you're all upset here we didn't
interact with addiction interact with
the county a county attorney
briefly today uh uh no they
they spoke to us
apparently there had been a lawsuit
filed by the media
to get the video released and
they're going to be arguments made to a
superior court jail
and they're going to decide whether to
release it to the public or not
your your i would hope that your uh
your network joins the lawsuit to free
all of these videos last question
i just want to just want to be clear
here y'all offered for the county
attorney to talk to the state attorney
general
and the governor i think i i
i offered him directly to talk to the
attorney general's office to get an
interpretation on the law
and he refused he refused and we showed
we showed him the law and he refused
to look at the law did anyone else
offered us the government
in a very elementary way explain when
you're not given all that footage what
questions remain how it is that the
footage that you have not gotten
as a lawyer what are you wondering it's
very simple it's not even as a lawyer as
my eight-year-old daughter would
understand they are trying to hide
something
they don't want us to see everything so
thank you all for your attention
we will have a press conference at 11
a.m
tomorrow with the results of our
independent autopsy right here from the
right here
and we thank miss gwen carl for being
present here is where air gardener's
mother
or head bowed heavenly father we thank
you even in the midst of chaos and
confusion
even in the midst of corruption and
wickedness in high places we thank you
for the opportunity
to carry forth the manner the banner and
the
mantle of justice father god we have to
continue to embrace
this family stand with this community as
we demand
justice father open every closed door
shine a light on every dark place remove
every
shadow of deception father that justice
may prevail
and this community and this family may
be put at ease and comfort
and all these things we ask in your
precious name jesus name we pray amen
amen
thank you christopher
um
um
happy
you